hey guys it's justine and i'm so excited
because i haven't even told you guys
officially yet but i got a new studio
and i'm currently in it and to go with
this new studio we have a new vacuum i
am so excited about this so a huge thank
you to lg for sponsoring this video this
is lg's core zero all-in-one this is
like a studio warming gift i'm so
excited to unbox this and lg said that
they put some items in here in case i
needed some extra mess uh i think that
some of the mess may have spilled out so
good thing i'm unboxing something that
can clean this all up let's do just that
oh god i'm gonna hurt myself with this
one of these days
oh there's all kinds of things in here
oh so yeah here it is the sprinkle
container
it's already been emptied and it is
everywhere oh oh goodness we've got some
coffee
we've got some cereal
and we have a t-shirt
all right we've got some of our messy
items i'm gonna put them over here
what is this
this is not a toy it's for a doll use
only when launching direct upward from
okay oh i think this is like one of
those party poppers oh my
goodness
let me get this unboxed so i can get
this cleaned up i'll tell you one thing
these sprinkles smell delicious
there's more sprinkles
[Music]
look at this oh this also has a little
mop feature can't wait to try that out
whoa
i love this color it's so fancy oh we
have a battery oh we actually have two
batteries
[Music]
all right this is the all-in-one base
station this is what really powers this
thing this will charge it store it and
it even empties the bag so you don't
have to empty the vacuum bag yourself
this will do it for you
all right so i have everything unboxed
now it's time to set this up because i'm
starting to freak out a little bit about
all these sprinkles everywhere
oh my goodness
this place is a disaster
okay it's all set up i'm about to clean
up my mess but i want to walk you guys
through some of the features of why this
is so cool this thing can get you up to
120 minutes of clean time there's two
rechargeable batteries and the best
thing is this will auto charge as soon
as you dock it to the tower and not only
will it do that but as soon as you dock
it it will automatically empty the bag
these batteries are removable and this
one is charging these are easily
swappable
and when you dock it it charges and
empties the container there it goes
emptying
we haven't even cleaned anything yet up
here is the display you can start or
stop emptying the bag you can select
various modes this will also show you
your battery life and it'll let you know
when you need to replace the bag and i
love that this is all just a little
touch screen the storage on this thing
is awesome because everything is all
self-contained i love that you can put
the mop right here on the side we'll
definitely go over more about the
mopping but i love that it has its own
little home
so on this side we have the attachment
for pet hair and i have a pet but i
think i actually shed more than my pet
maddy this is for your hair
and on this side we have two other
attachments
for various cleaning situations a little
cleaning brush and that's all the
storage
easily hidden away the maintenance is
actually really easy i love that they
have removable and washable filters this
does come with an extra one but i love
that i can just wash this out and reuse
it
and inside here this is where all of the
debris goes from the vacuum these are
disposable and you can get extra bags
and you won't have to worry about all of
the extra mess you can just throw this
away and inside here we have another air
filter this also can just be washed out
and reused and that's recommended to do
once every three months
i think this means i finally get to
clean my floors now
oh i hate it so much i hate it so much
it's gotta go it's gotta go i can't wait
to clean this up i've already made quite
a mess but i feel like if i'm gonna do
this i might as well make more of a mess
look at this look at maddie please don't
eat the cereal
oh wow
oh what do we have here a little bit of
pillow stuffing basically what it looks
like after i brush my hair because all
of my hair just falls out
i'm stressed
this is me stressed ready to clean i
also love this extendable handle
i can get an extra nine and a half
inches
of cleaning length we've got all of the
touch controls here let's start cleaning
whoa
oh my
look at that
we're going to turbo
wow
can we just pause for a second and say
i've been vacuuming this carpet for the
past
three or four years and it has never
looked so clean like i'm not even like
this is this is not even an exaggeration
like it's i don't even know i'm
speechless
so this is a compressor feature this
actually lets you double the storage of
this tank
let's keep cleaning
[Music]
at this point i'm no longer cleaning for
the video and i'm doing this for myself
so there's still like some little
sprinkles that are kind of like wedged
in between
the crevasse here of the carpet so i'm
gonna swap accessories and just really
get in there i also have an ant problem
so i basically have just supplied a
buffet for all of the ants
that uh are around here so i've really
got to get these cleaned up quickly i
like that i can just swap these
accessories so quickly and so easily
we're gonna do some detail work now look
at ant do you see him right there
oh yeah
there's so many just in this little
court this is really great for some hard
to reach areas
like behind here
sprinkles everywhere
[Music]
oh this is nice
oh another ant
like i'm not even joking like this ant
was carrying a sprinkle he's taking a
sprinkle back to his home oh look at
that this one's cool
oh my gosh there's a fog up here
buh-bye
oh another spider
oh for vents
i'm not gonna lie i've never cleaned a
vent before that's
probably not something that i should
admit with this like it's actually quite
easy because i can reach it so i'm done
vacuuming and now i want to mop so i'm
going to empty this out to show you guys
how awesome this is the fact that i can
just dock it and it empties
automatically
there it
goes bye-bye
the bag is emptied now it's time to mop
this is so cool filled this up with
water you can choose your water level
and you can attach the mops to the
bottom all right let's fill this up with
some water this is actually the tank it
looks like it's the cover but no no
surprise this is the water tank
[Music]
then after you get these wet they just
velcro right onto the bottom and then
you just attach it like all of the other
attachments
something that happens very often when
i'm drinking my drink i
[Music]
oops
oops i think that needs to be mopped up
[Music]
all right i've never used a mop like
this before
so let's go
whoa
look at this okay ready let's let's get
cleaned up
oh yeah mop that up mop clean that up
that's nice since i just moved into the
studio i uh i also don't want to admit
i've not actually mopped or cleaned the
floors yet so
[Applause]
this is this is the first cleaning
wow this is awesome
it like moves the mop for me like i
don't i'm putting forth zero effort
this looks good this is this is nice
i'm having a really good time
[Applause]
wow
now i kind of want to put the camera
away and like just really
do this entire office this is so great
i've actually never had an electric mop
before so this is so cool when i push
the button it kind of just like takes
off it like self propels itself
so i don't really have to like put forth
much effort to really push it it just
goes i also like that it doesn't use a
lot of water too so it's not making
these floors like super soppy so as i
was about to end this video i realized i
forgot about the party popper so i
thought what better way to end this
video than to celebrate by ruining all
of the beautiful work that i just did by
opening this thing up okay hold the top
section with your left hand
hold the bottom section with your right
hand then rotate in the direction of the
arrows i just do it yeah let's celebrate
oh oh
[Music]
what again a huge thank you to lg for
sponsoring this video you guys are
amazing i will put a link in the
description if you guys want to get more
information about the lg cord zero this
thing is so fun and it's actually made
me really happy and excited to clean
with that being said
we have more mess see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
you